i'm boss abdul karim presenter and
reporter at deutsche welle i present
the format ogg and now
i'm not in the studio but on my way
to a refugee home
because i want to ask kitchen what
they're doing today it's the festival of sacrifice
many arab people many muslims are
celebrating  the festival and yes how are you
doing you are celebrating today completely different
circumstances than what you did in your home country how
you did it in your home country
we also brought pens and notepads for
the children and that was when i
was here for the first
time  told me i should come
with only the coolest one because only
speaks german now what are you doing
also the sacrificial festival
usually the whole extended family comes together
grandfather uncle or etc
i know that myself from more than sacrificial festival
is if you are somehow alone
it  a very strange feeling and that's
exactly what you're describing all the time now
it's you can see the
whole thing  n children don't shake hands
now that big party celebrated
for me it's funny on one side
I'm the journalist told is I
want to ask questions I want to give the
refugees a voice at the
same time I noticed sometimes that
I feel the same way and get
emotional but  then again
to look at it from a distance but it's
not so easy to do something differently
there were
i don't know what in such cool moments
where you really forget that you are a
refugee accommodation because the
joy the children had everyone is happy
then  at that moment it was okay
her husband was murdered in syria she
had taken three children with her and can
now go to berlin about two
months ago there was a process right here she teaches
two language courses a day because that’s
important to her it’s good she doesn’t understand
everything yet but hello  how are you and
what's
your name i'm in istria so yes on the
best way to go there
yes i think that's cool company wi  r
meet again next four
weeks discovered i was in
refugee camp a border with libya
i was in future is a border with
syria i was in lebanon and it was
always like that i did my job and
went home and for the first
time since  there are a lot of refugees here in
berlin i notice i go home and
say yes you can help too
and i say no you are not a part of
the story but you report about
the story but in this case
it was sometimes a mixture that’s why i
come  i keep going to the
same refugee camp or
refugee accommodation and say although it
is far from the city and was
said to be on the outskirts of berlin but yes
i think i will keep coming back
to see how the children are doing and how
the people are doing here  and now I'm going